this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much pleasure to be here
at Cornell I think this is my first time
I'm going to use an old-fashioned
pointer so that the folks in Geneva can
see me can you see me in the pointer
here guys and I can't hear them right
anyway I hope they can thick in here and
see they'll wave yeah yeah are they
waiting so so what I'm going to talk
about is is actually kind of a simple
study that we thought was going to be
simple when we started and it turned out
to uncover some very interesting aspects
that we had not anticipated about
something about Silas structure and
function now you may think that xylem
that's been studied for a very long time
it's it's a fairly well known structure
of different kinds of cells right
there's vessel members there's tracheids
fibers I'm assuming I don't have to
introduce these concepts to all of you
plant science folks here at in cornell
and all of these are arranged in a
tissue and of course different species
and different groups of plants have have
different kinds okay but one thing that
was known from early on is that the
structure of xylem is fairly complex
these things are not just pipes that run
straight their pipes that run crooked in
this case this is this is about a two
millimeter by two millimeter by 30
centimeters the 30 35 millimeters
section so it's sort of been compressed
vertically so that you can see that
these things kind of wander around these
are vessels you can see if they're
interconnected and in fact this section
in this section this is all the way back
from sort of the 70s need to overlap one
another to actually they're from the
same section they're just separated so
that you can see that's just a whole lot
of spaghetti in here
and we had some questions about about
xylem movement that we wanted to ask ask
and one of the things that a complex
series of interconnected pipes will do
which is something that I did not know
before I talk to an engineer in any
engineers in the in the audience is that
you can actually when you have if you
have three pipes and one goes straight
through one has a bit of a resistance
and another one has a bit more of a
resistance and they're interconnected in
this fashion that even though water may
enter in to this side on all three going
that way and water may exit on all three
on the other side do a pressure
differential part of the system may be
flowing backwards is everybody okay with
that idea that you can actually have
backwards flow even though it's coming
in and going out the same three tubes so
this would be called I think an emergent
property of inner and interconnected set
you know the system of pipes and that's
a very interesting property because we
were wondering whether reverse flow in
this kind of system might explain how
vascular pathogens that is xylem
dwelling in our case do they know about
does I'll elaphus IDEO sahir the cause
of Pierce's disease in grapevine anybody
know about that it may was all the you
know made the big headlines in
California a number of years ago it's a
xylem dwelling bacteria that is
transmitted by a xylem feeding insect
and usually the insect feeds in you know
shoots in the upper part of the canopy
but over years the infection can get
down into the roots and kill the plant
basically it's called Pierce's disease
and of course if it's in the xylem how
is it going backwards when the xylem is
always supposed to be flowing you know
to leave so that's somewhat up with
somewhat of a mystery how the how a
disease can spread downward but maybe if
there's some of these that are flowing
in reverse that could account for that
maybe these kind of interconnections
whether its downward or a crossword if
we understood the interconnections then
we could explain how embolism spread I'm
assuming everybody here understands a
little bit that the xylem system is
under tension water under tension can
cavitate or embolize and sort of suck
air let's say cause an air bubble to
occur in there and that that can spread
and obviously wreak havoc with the with
the system of transporting water so we
had a couple of these questions and then
we asked well do we know about how this
system is interconnected in order to
answer these questions and we thought
well maybe we don't know so we were able
to get a grant and harvest a very good
post doc Craig brodersen who has now got
another post doc at UC Santa Cruz and we
sent him to our friendly neighborhood
advance synchrotron night light source
in Berkeley this is what Berkeley looks
like all the time just kidding nice
picture of the San Francisco Bay you
know where all the men are strong all
the women are beautiful and all the
scientists are above average but it's
it's a big place inside there that went
over much better when I was talking in
Minneapolis the other day but you can
put up you can put a plant inside here
with this x-ray source and you can get a
very high-resolution x-ray tomographic
view a three-dimensional view of the
stem now this is a live plant and we
didn't start with live plants partly
because this is an air stage and it has
to rotate in a very precise manner in
order to get a 3d image and it's a lot
easier to do that if all you have is a
stick of wood and we were only
interested in the xylem structure so we
began by
putting sticks of wood here and rotating
them around and getting this information
and i'll get back to the to the living
plant in a in a little while but so what
we get with that so I guess Neil I
forgot to tell you should have brought
some popcorn but chips are probably just
as well so here's an example that I'm
going to let just let play of what the
raw data looks like if you scan through
this section as we're scanning down this
is across five millimeters this is the
pith and you can see that the pith is
sort of changing this is a dry piece of
wood these are all the xylem vessels
okay I'm going to stop this and rewind
it so lots of interesting things that
piff goes from being full of tissue to
being empty but that's not what's
important what's important is what's
going on in and all these xylem vessels
and what you see is the big ones and
they don't change much but next time I
play this now just take a look at some
of these places where there are small
cells just pick a spot I mean anywhere
you pick and I'm going to play and what
you're going to find out is that these
small cells kind of dance around we had
a lot of fun doing this when we were and
you see they appear and disappear and
sometimes connect over and sometimes
move over and there's a couple over here
that just sort of shift entirely okay
but anyway so so the idea there is that
is that we get raw data that is just
basically a stack of of images they used
to make movies out of this and it took a
long time this doesn't take so long and
you get a very high resolution and you
can start to see then how these these
these the the sort of pie shaped pieces
between raised because that's what you
have here these are aligned up you know
radially in files and that
sometimes there are vessels that go from
one way and connect over to another
array a lot of times there are small
vessels that interconnect these big
vessels and there's a whole lot of
complexity in the way these vessels are
interconnected and that's what we wanted
to try to model mathematically okay now
so so this is just an example of one
cross section with a pit labeled here
now the grapevine bears leaves on either
side of the of the stem of the shoe and
those are called the lateral sides and
because these are called lateral sides
something has to be dorsal and something
has to be ventral I guess even though
those are terms we don't normally use
for plants but that's what this is
called dorsal ventral and then lateral
and the lateral sides you may be able to
see a little bit here look like they're
a little squished in compared to the
dorsal ventral side maybe the vessels
are a little bit smaller than here and
we'll see a little bit more detail about
some of those properties that they have
but as I said there are sort of in
radial files separated by rays and this
just explains that in fact every pixel
of this is about four and a half microns
and so we have four and a half micron
pixels this way and also four and a half
micron pixels this way vertically so
that they're called voxels since they're
a volume and in order to analyze this
you can't just do it on image J you have
to do it on some kind of software and
then a VSO software is kind of like
image J on the steroids you can do all
kinds of interesting things with this
software so I'm just going to sort of
take you through a little quickly the
process that we would go through to
analyze a section so we start with one
slice somewhere in the in the in the
field and then as as I click down you'll
see things change here and this is just
keeping track of all the processes that
you've done and the image
will change depending on what that
process was now the first thing you do
is you kind of blur out the in-between
parts and that you see something showed
up here you see almost no difference
there I don't know if you notice that
but I'll just go up and down a couple of
times it just kind of gets a lot
smoother in between the cells you just
kind of smooth things out now i have
actually no idea of all the image
analysis stuff that's being done but I
can explain what the results of it are
once you've done that step you can try
to sort of segment this into black
versus white and you can play around
with settings to make it a little bit
more white and then the nice thing about
this software is that when you take a
spot here for instance if you just click
on this you know the magic wand idea i
click here then it will sort of connect
all of that same color basically which
is black and white so all of the white
that's not found it and it will connect
it up and down from wherever you clicked
it in and also show a vertical sections
that through this thing if you want to
so what it's sort of a volume oriented
3d reconstruction software anyway so we
have to have somebody go through and
click on these things and say yeah okay
that's that that's a vessel that's the
one that I want and what happens is you
can take two of these things or one of
them and you can identify it and give it
a name I think and then turn it into
just that you can tell the software okay
only show me what I named here and once
they've been named by this guy Jacob
that's his name he's the undergraduate
who was doing all of the driving of this
software then you can generate of volume
rendering so this is just a quick movie
to sort of show and you'll see right
here a lot of dancing around the vessels
as it scans through and then basically
once you've identified them you can get
sort of 3d render
that you can rotate around and it's a
lot of fun to watch but because it's
done mathematically you can do virtual
cross-sections this way and because of
the volume filling you can actually
identify these and then have it tell you
where is that volume and in addition to
the volume it can tell you where the
midpoint of it is where the edges of it
are and how close it is to its nearest
neighbor so this was all preliminary
because what we wanted to do was we
wanted to find out how these things are
interconnected and make a model out of
it so for instance but this is a
software was very helpful in being able
to show when for instance you had a
connection because they were close
together and when there was space in
between them when they diverged when
you're looking through a cross-section
you may see it in this this way when
it's at one part of the stem and then
farther apart when it's another part of
the stem and you can volume render that
and see what it's trying to tell you but
now we had the question well how close
is close enough okay or if they're this
close then are we going to consider them
connected or not okay and another
question is when you have a connection
then what's the hydraulic resistance but
for water flow through that connection
well that actually can come from the
literature because some people have
already looked at that but what we had
to do is we had to go back to the
drawing board a bit and make a and make
a measurement on a cross-section here we
have introduced into one vessel at the
end of the stem what we called a
fiduciary marker and the marker is just
some silicon resin so that when we made
a cross-section of that and put that in
the sem we could find out where that
was then we could identify from that
which vessels were close to it then we
could look under the SEM a detail and
when you see a pit between two vessels
then you know that they're connected
okay so these are typically you know the
typical pit fields between vessels they
have a pit membrane our middle imela
across them and those have been pretty
well studied so this is just showing the
vessel vessel fits over here and the
vessel to / income it fits over there so
then what we could do is we we could
look at all of the cells how far they
would be measured apart in the end the
x-ray image and whether that are not
they had a pits with adjacent vessels
and this is a graph showing anywhere
down to about eight or 10 12 14 by about
14 microns between there's the amount of
cells with with pits between them the
mount vessels with fits between and
dropped off sort of precipitously so we
figured if it's 40 microns or less
between we're going to say that's a
connection if it's greater than 14
microns that's not a connection so
that's how we kind of calibrated the the
distance that the information we could
get from the x-ray from the anatomical
information about whether to call it a
connection or not any questions about
that so far so some week one of the
things that we discovered was that we we
saw some of those vessels that sort of
dance between big vessels the little
ones that dance between big ones
actually we look at those and those are
actually open so I don't know whether
they be called a pit or not anyway but
that was something we sort of discovered
late that even that that it may not be
the typical vessel to vessel get that
has a pit membrane and has a resistance
across it but rather an open pit those
might turn out to be those will turn out
to be in
later but so once you've decided how
close they need to be to be connected
then you can let the software go through
and not only trace the center of the
vessel but also trace where there were
connections and this is all kind of
off-the-shelf automatic after you've
gone through that process I described
but you can see sometimes it thinks that
there's connections right in you know in
the middle of nowhere basically and a
lot of these connections look really
crazy so we ended up having to hire a
mother postdoc Eric Lee who is an
engineer type guy and he was able to
develop the algorithms that we needed to
take what these old software told us and
actually turn into something that we
thought was more realistic and that he
could actually model as far as flow was
concerned and then we went ahead and
checked weather checked what the data
look like in terms of where the
connections were and so on so one thing
for instance was if you if you consider
a vessel where zero degrees is in the
radial direction and 90 degrees is 90
degrees from that the connections are
mostly at zero degrees with some at 90
degrees and in the in the dorsal ventral
zone same thing in the in the lateral
zones but this made a lot of sense
because generally vessels are in radial
files so this would be a zero degree
connection and they're also usually next
to if they're going to be connected
they'd be connected at right angles to
that rather than at sort of just any old
name but that was so that's just one
description we had a bunch of
descriptions you know that the dorsal
ventral vessels are generally bigger
than the lateral
nestles there closer to the pit and more
interconnected but all of this is just
descriptive what we really wanted was we
really wanted to make take all of this
interconnected stuff on a particular
stem or a particular section of stem and
make a mathematical model a flow model
an engineering model about how water
would flow through this system because
that's what we were really interested in
so this is what Eric did we took we took
a bunch of information from the
literature about for instance what the
force the pore size distribution would
be in a typical pit what the pit
conductivity would be in a bunch of
other stuff and came up with a flow
basically from one pressure at one side
to another pressure at the other side
just to see how this would behave and
this is the first ever run that we did
and what this shows is in the red color
its flow going in one direction it
actually doesn't matter which one but
let's say from the bottom to the top and
the blue direction and its intensity is
flow going in the opposite direction so
already in this particular section that
we that we analyze we've already got
enough complex interconnections and
enough differences in resistant
resistance and so on that you can get
flow in the wrong direction in a
reasonable model of what the you know
what the xylem would be like in a in a
grapevine so that was one of the things
we wanted to ask the question about
whether you can have reverse flow and
you can another thing was has to do with
embolism spread I'll get the embolism
prepare a little bit later but is there
any pattern that you can see that
relates to the structure of the xylem or
do things just embolize let's say
randomly well here's an example of a
living stem now and notice that you
don't see many
the vessels and that's because there are
a whole bunch of other vessels that you
can actually pick out by I but they are
almost the same color as the background
because they're filled with water and
x-rays are basically telling you with
the density of the tissue and that's
mostly the density of water so basically
all of these vessels that you see here
are embolized vessels and this was on a
stem of a plant that we dried out on
purpose then took it to Berkeley then
set it up in this in this x-ray and then
x-rayed it for a number of hours and got
sequential images along this five
millimeter section and what the images
showed was all the ones in blue here
were the ones that were already
capitated already analyzed when we
started so at x 0 and through the rest
of the eight and a half hours you can
see how it spread as the colors go I
can't see colors very well but you can
see a couple of Emma lysing here and so
on and and one thing that you could see
very clearly was that they tended to
embolize in groups corresponding to that
radio file which makes sort of sense
because those are the ones that are
typically interconnected but we had some
cases where so if you look down at this
this lower half for instance this groove
which i think is red I'm red-green
colorblind so is this a red color here
okay this group in red embolized at the
same time that this group in blues at
blue this group in blue and this is
yellow or green from joke yo thank you
so we got a red file in blue file and
this yellow guy and if you scan through
you find that that yellow guys switched
allegiance here
right to the blue somewhere in that
section you can see in the 3d
reconstruction it's going from being
connected to a red guy to being
connected to a glue guy here so that
explains why they would why all of these
things would embolize at the same time
is because they were connected by one of
these by the yellow guy so I think in
terms of sort of conclusions for this
part of the work we think that we can
use hi res cat scanning to construct
accurate 3d models of how the xylem is
interconnected and it's a lot of work
it's a lot less work than doing
everything by hand but it's still a lot
of work and we're still working on that
I think the 3d software to rotate these
images and makes virtual sections
through them is very valuable we can see
a lot of interesting things like those
bridging cells that we didn't we didn't
even know about and I think the idea
back flow and perhaps spread of xylem
dwelling bacteria may may be an
important that the complexity of
interconnections and the idea that you
can have that flow may be important for
that and also that those 3d
interconnections may be very important
for the pattern of embolism script any
questions about that so far I'm used to
kind of interacting a little bit more
with the class so I really encourage you
to ask questions nobody I know
everybody's embarrassed sure yes every
good one bush with the gas the
interconnections what's the space there
that's that's a really good question so
let me see now so if your if you were
thinking about this gap that that gap is
that gap is the is them I don't know is
the bay bridge for xylo exile Allah can
get through there no problem that is
essentially open the pores in the in the
pit membranes of a typical vessel to
vessel connection those are too small
for as I thought I Lola and the thinking
is it desired lower extreme excrete
enzymes that degrade carbohydrates and
they digest their way through those
probably causing a cavitation when that
happens I mean but but that's where
that's where the spread of the bacteria
and the anatomy of the xylem and it's
you know 3d interconnections that's kind
of where these things converge to the
same kind of question that's why we
wanted to model modeled it actually the
model that I showed that it included
these kind of connections yet because we
sort of discovered those after we had
figured out the model good question
anybody else yes sir
that's that's a very good question so
and I don't know no well what yes you'll
hire a postdoc who knows and that solved
so so Eric Eric is actually a postdoc in
engineering and so the the the values
that you can get that from the
literature about well one value for
instance is just a pessoa equation for a
given diameter a vessel and the flow
through them that's easy right okay the
hard one is is how hard is it for water
to go from here and go across when
there's a pic connection and as it turns
out there are there are ways so you can
take a piece of stem and you can glue
using superglue of course glue a glass
capillary that's been pulled down pretty
fine glue a capillary into one vessel
then you can send water with some dye
through there and look at the other end
and see where that's coming out now
usually what we try to do then then then
you can glue up that side and if it
comes out of an adjacent vessel and the
vessels are fairly close then you can be
pretty confident that they are connected
in between there and that then you can
measure the flow coming in and going out
and the pressure differential and then
you can calculate a sort of a hydraulic
conductivity of that junction so so
we've done a little bit of that in our
lab but other folks have done a lot of
that in their labs so so that pic
conductivity is something that we just
put into this this hydraulic equation
along with all the other typical is
shins of a you know hydraulic equation
it's are you an engineer pad guy it's a
very complex set of equations right
because you got all these vessels in all
these interconnections that's why we had
to hire Eric to do it is that okay yeah
yeah that's we have no idea how this
would work out we just said let's just
model this based on you know physical
principles good question anybody else am
i doing time was okay yes sir it's not
obviously why they're perfect rating why
there is back okay so you should have
stopped me way back when I was talking
about this but you didn't say well okay
okay that'd be basically if the pressure
here at this connection let's let's just
say for a moment that this connection is
has very little resistance if the
president here is lower as higher than
the pressure here then water's going to
go back that way so so and you can just
make up a scenario these are all equal
sized pipes with slightly different
resistance so if this one has a lot of
some resistance then then bend the
pressure downstream of this resistance
is going to be you know a lower than
this pressure and if this one has a lot
more of resistance then the pressure
here is going to be a lot lower than
that pressure and and they both may be
lower than this pressure here with no
resistance so basically it's this is
really from here to here is just a
connection and whether it's oriented
backwards or whether
into the sign and some extent doesn't
really make any difference so the water
doesn't know that it's going backwards
is just flowing down downhill is that
now that's just hand wave but when I
asked the question that works yeah okay
so so apparently the engineer guys have
known this and if you are a young
engineer and you design a system of
pipes and this does it you get fired or
something like that you know that
usually you don't want things to work
that way but I think that's why they
always use pipes are the same diameter
because then then you don't have that
big of a problem this is great anybody
else so the let's say we talked about
embolism loops bread so I'm going to
quickly now talk just about this repair
because at first we were just putting
sticks in the in the HR CT and we
decided and I don't remember who was the
weather Craig wanted to do this or mark
Matthews my colleague said you know
let's put a live plant in there and see
if we can see embolisms or something now
the guys at Berkeley said you guys are
nuts you know you don't go anywhere near
that thing you don't have anything
living in that thing you know there's
all the shielding and stuff and they
just thought the plant was just going to
die well it didn't die in fact in fact
the plants we brought him back out to
the greenhouse and they were fine and so
just as background though other people
have used NMR or MRI nuclear magnetic
resonance or magnetic resonance imaging
to want to say that there's been vessels
that are embolized so here's a corn root
and you see these three black dots and
now there's only one black dot because
the other two are full and that means
that you know that water has filled
these these vessels that were that we're
embolized so this has been around for a
little while but as you can see the
resolutions not great if you have a
foreign route with really
vessels that you can see them we
actually got a little better resolution
on grapevines and we're also able to
show so this is a living plant and you
know you can see them light up here and
when they where there was two to dark
ones here okay but again the resolutions
not great and we put a living plant in
there and it survived and for instance
we would make we would make a CT scan of
this plant that show some dark vessels
that means capitated vessels and then
you can look and see on the image that
there were vessels that work
water-filled no problem and you can kind
of line that up with a hand section of
the same thing so so for instance this
is pointing to number one's pointing to
two adjacent vessels here that we would
say are connected and the big one is
embolize the little one is full of water
okay but as soon as we start looking at
these we saw these little blobs these
little like warts and we thought what
the heck are those things I mean most of
the vessels you know our round but we
saw one that are like moon shaped and
what are those blogs well the thought
was hmm maybe those blobs are little
water droplets that are starting to
refill these vessels and and mark canny
had already come up with this idea so so
as background I should I probably should
have said this already you know that we
get embolism that's a bad thing and
there's lots been been lots of of
evidence that embolism can be somehow
reversed so you can have a loss of
hydraulic conductivity in the day and
then a gain of hydraulic conductivity
than during the night or maybe sometime
later in the day and so so the search
was on for finding out how the heck
Asylum vessel can be empty at one time
of the day and the whole system is under
tension and yet and somehow refill you
know later that day or maybe overnight
when the system is under tension so so
Martin canny hasn't used cryo sem and
found little drops and said hey maybe
it's water being sort of pushed in there
by the adjacent cells but the problem
with cryo of course is that you're never
sure if it's an artifact or not because
you freeze it and water can distill and
condense and so on so that kind of got
left alone for for a while while
everybody was chasing after this and
also these droplets now you can see that
they in this virtual long section that
they look a little bit more like drops
they kind of look a little bit like tile
Oh Sees but obviously kylo seas are a
permanent thing they are not a drop it's
a outgrowth of an adjacent brinkema cell
and and we basically just kept looking
at these and finally once we got the 3d
sort of reconstruction figured out we
were we you know to our to our amazement
realize that what we were seeing was
drops and they may be drops that you
could see clearly as individual drops or
they may be things that were sort of
more big blobs which may have been drops
that just coalesced and so what we could
do is we could look at the same section
over time so this would be an example of
an experiment where we took a grapevine
dried it out real good came in at0 time
and this is just one long section for
from from one section where you can see
three pretty clear vessels and then we
would maybe ree water the point or in
one case in the first plant we did we
actually just put it in there and at
time 0 we saw
you can see that there was drops or
something so he just left the vinyl um
didn't rewire it at all and over time it
refilled itself so sometimes if the vine
is very supplants very stressed you have
to water it and then it will refill
sometimes it just does it maybe it was
ready to do it on its own but you can
see over time and up finally at about
four hours everything had been refilled
now you know we don't have a minute by
minute we it's more like every 30
minutes or so that we can scan this but
clearly things were getting refilled and
and you can see a lot of interesting
detail about you know one of the last
things to go might be a bubble in the
middle of the vessel or on the side of
the best episode it's that's a very good
question this is for hours in the in the
dark but but also because of the shaking
that it because of the way you have to
you know pulled the plant I think I
showed what the yeah because of the way
you have to hold this plan everything is
sort of enclosed anyway this one has got
a Ted sticking up above it so yeah so
you would expect though that it's low
transpiration conditions for sure for
sure so here's an example for instance
if since the sense the software will
allow you to say okay I'm then identify
this vessel or this vessel or this
vessel then you can and then it will
also say I'm going to identify these
things as drops tell me everywhere that
they're connected to and then it will
sort of show you all those drops then
you can actually calculate the volume of
the vessel and the volume of the drops
and the volume by difference of the air
so this shows for instance some of four
vessels and how that how they ultimately
all have no air at six hours and and
because we were able to track individual
drops at least in the early part of this
process we could say how big is the
volume of that
now compared to how big it is two hours
from now or four hours from and we could
actually calculate a droplet growth rate
and we could take all the drops in all
the surface area of that vessel and
calculate how fast it should take a
vessel to fill and basically the white
circles are our calculation based on a
drop growth rate that's not crop growth
rate drop on an independent sample then
from what we actually observe for these
things as to how quick the vessel could
be you know filled up with water and you
can see really good agreement little
disagreement here but basically the
vessels seem to be filling in a
consistent manner with what we calculate
for a drop to grow and in this case
there are some vessels that start
filling that is lower air volume and
then the air volume comes up and they
wander around and that may never go to
zero okay I'll show some some details
about that so that's what we would call
is refilling failure okay so if we zoom
in on this thing here we see it here
okay so we see some drops here some
drops here some big globs drop here
where's that water coming from adjacent
Frank well I'll get to better that's a
very good question so from you know I
don't know Frank's magic
so in this case for instance we've got
zero up to six hours at six hours this
one lonely vessel here which is this guy
has not filled but all the other ones
next to it have filled here's here's a
whole bunch of little ones and a lot of
drops and this whole group is is here
and it's full so and it's not for lack
of trying because by zooming in on that
one vessel you can see that there are
drops growing I mean I'm assuming that
that now by this point that these things
are growing over time and that they are
so the idea is well so so this oh so
this would be an example of where this
filming attempt somehow fails it ends up
being completely embolized but it makes
sense if these things are filling and
then after being full they come under
tension as the normal part of the xylem
is under tension then maybe this one
just cannot keep up with that and it's
empty because of because of the tension
in the rest of the xylem or at least
that's the model the we just as sort of
a sideline you can get lots of very cool
pictures of this sort of 3d and you
could zoom through there and get get
seasick doing that the the droplets
appeared to be forming forever Anjali on
the sides that are next to the radio
parenchymal cells and and this is not a
new idea other people have speculated
that this was going on but I think now
we have sort of the first evidence that
it does go on in vivo and that is that
you've got the radio parenchymal cells
here that it's probably carbohydrates
because if you girdle you can slow this
process down
our work with other folks if the only
way we can explain it is that the cells
somehow get well you know transport
sugars or whatever into the adjacent
xylem that those sugars then osmotically
from all the rest of this tissue draw
water in and that's what causes that the
water drop to grow that you can get
growth over time that the growth if it
happens to connect to the adjacent
vessel that's under tension then that's
probably not fast enough to keep that
water from flowing out but if it is fast
enough which means that this is where
things get interesting is that we don't
think this system when they're refilling
is all under tension it may be that
there's others island in other places
that are under tension and we certainly
when we measure the bulk of the tissue
we get a low water potential value so we
presume that it's under tension but it
may be that this is a very local
phenomenon and that when you've got a
bunch of cells they tend to do this in
groups all sort of trying to refill
that's very key illogical don't get me
wrong I'm not a feely ologist but I
think it's pretty much what we think is
going on that that that maybe that maybe
even in the ones that we think are full
maybe they're also getting carbon from
their adjacent parenchymal cells and and
maybe that they're kind of relieving the
tension by adding some pumping into it
and while they're being relieved of
tension all the recipes guys can refill
and that after their Dunn's been filling
then the whole system can come back
under tension least this is our this is
this is our hypothesis we have evidence
anyway that the drop growth rate can
explain the refilling we have evidence
that drops congeal and get the space
gets less and less we have evidence that
that bubbles can be right in the middle
of the vessel and then the next
time we see them they're gone so
presumably they've gotten compressed and
you need a little bit of it can't be
under tension for that to happen we also
have evidence that the bubbles can be
near the edge and disappear which could
mean that the air is sort of going out
into the applicant lab somehow but
bottom line i think the weight of the
evidence is is strongly favoring the
idea of a sugar or some kind of
carbohydrate transport followed by
osmosis and you know just water water
movement yes might not be under tension
is there any evidence to suggest that
the end
pours in this island and embolize
section of xylem close that's a very
good question Missy holbrook at Harvard
came up with the idea some time ago that
the the pits so actually it's not it's
not just the ends that are a concern
it's the ends and the sides and
everywhere right if the whole tissue is
under tension then how is it that that
you can get water under maybe slight
pressure or let's say no tension anyway
filling these things and as soon as it
touches it touches a side that's in
continuity with anything under tension
it should just get sucked right away so
she came up with the idea that that the
reason why pits are designed the way
they are is that there might be a little
bit of a hydrophobic pocket right around
the pit so that when water is filling
this it actually doesn't wet the part of
the pit that connects it to the adjacent
cell and that it might be just at the
last moment when all the when the
pressure is enough to cause all of those
things to make a connection so so in a
way you could say that that's like you
know closing off the connections until
they're ready to to be connected
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu